>> Tucker: AS IF 8:33 EASTERN
TIME ON AUGUST 9, 2021, AN DREW
CUOMO IS STILL THE GOVERNOR OF
NEW YORK.
CAN'T TELL YOU HOW MUCH LONGER.
MATT FINN HAS MORE.
>> BRITTANY COMMISSO HAS ACCUSED
GOVERNOR CUOMO OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT.
SHE SAID WHILE TAKING THE
SELFIE, THE GOVERNOR
INAPPROPRIATELY TOUCHED HER.
>> I THEN FELT WHILE TAKING A
SELFIE HIS HAND GO DOWN MY BACK
ON TO MY BUTT.
HE STARTED RUBBING IT.
NOT SLIDING IT, NOT QUICKLY
BRUSHING OVER IT.
RUBBING MY BUTT.
>> COMMISSO ALLEGES THE GOVERNOR
GAVE HER HUGS THAT SHE SAYS WERE
NOT THE TYPE THAT HE WOULD GIVE
HER MOTHER OR BROTHER BUT THE
TYPE SEEKING SEXUAL
SATISFACTION.
THEY WERE NOT WELCOME.
THE GOVERNOR HAS DENIED
INAPPROPRIATELY TOUCHING ANYONE.
HE RELEASED A REEL OF HIM
KISSING AND HUGGING PEOPLE
SAYING IT'S A NORMAL BEHAVIOR.
THERE'S GROWING CALLS FOR CUOMO
TO RESIGN.
EVEN THE PRESIDENT SAID CUOMO
SHOULD STEP DOWN.
THE NEW YORK ASSEMBLY IS
CONDUCTING AN IMPEACHMENT
INVESTIGATION.
THEY ONLY NEED A SIMPLY MAJORITY
VOTE TO MOVE FORWARD WITH THE
TRIAL, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: MATT FINN.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR THAT.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: SO ANDREW CUOMO IS A
WEIRDO, A BUTT RUBBER.
BUT TOMORROW WE'LL SEE THAT BUT
TAKE TIME TO DEFEND THE CHIEF
BODY BUILDING BROTHER ON CNN.
IN THE MIDDLE OF THIS SCANDAL
THAT MAY REMOVE HIS BROTHER FROM
OFFICE, CHRIS CUOMO DECIDED TO
GO ON VACATION.
COULD THIS REALLY BE A VACATION?
CNN BROKE INTO THEIR EXTENDED
COVERAGE OF STURGIS TO ANSWER
THAT QUESTION.
YES, IT'S A REAL VACATION.
HERE'S THEIR POSITION ON HIS
VACATION.
>> TELLING A WELL-OFF HOST TO
HANG OUT BY THE POOL IS NOT
PUNISH MEANT.
IT'S B.C. WHEN SAYS I'M DURING A
VACATION ON A SCANDAL.
SCOLD AGO HOST IN PUBLIC.
SAYING WHAT THEY DID WAS
INAPPROPRIATE.
THAT'S AN ACTUAL PUNISHMENT.
CHRIS WILL HAVE A SURREAL
BIRTHDAY ON MONDAY.
HE ALWAYS TAKES HIS BIRTH WEEK
OFF, ALWAYS TAKES IT OFF WORK,
THIS WEEK HE WILL BE ABSENT
WHILE HIS BROTHER IS FIGHTING
FOR HIS POLITICAL LIFE.
DON'T BELIEVE IT.
I CHECKED THE SOURCES ON HIS
STAFF AND THEY CONFIRMED THAT HE
BOOKED THIS TIME OFF MONTHS AGO.
>> Tucker: CAN THAT BE REAL?
HE HAS TO BE A PLANT FROM MSNBC.
THERE'S NO CHANCE THAT HE'S
ACTUALLY ACTING ON BEHALF OF
CNN.
ANYWAY, WE'RE PLAYING YOU THE
TAPE.
YOU CAN EVALUATE IT FOR HIMSELF.
THIS IS CNN'S POSITION.
WHENEVER ONE OF OUR ANCHORS
TAKES A VACATION, IT'S REAL.
IF YOU WORK AT FOX NEWS, ALL
VACATIONS ARE PRETENDED.
THAT WAS DON LEMON'S POSITION
WHEN WE WENT FISHING A COUPLE
YEARS AGO.
>> TUCKER CARLSON IS ON
VACATION.
FOX NEWS HAS A LONG HISTORY ON
THEIR HOSTS HEADING OUT ON
VACATION AFTER THEY BECOME
UNGULFED IN CONTROVERSY
ICO.
>> TWO OTHER QUICK THINGS ABOUT
CHRIS CUOMO IN TOTAL SINCERITY.
ONE, YOU'RE NOT RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE MISBEHAVIOR OF YOUR
RELATIVES.
SORRY.
YOU DIDN'T CHOOSE THEM.
YOU'RE NOT RESPONSIBLE FOR
ANYBODY ELSE'S MISBEHAVIOR.
ONLY YOU'RE OWN.
IT'S THE BASIS OF AMERICAN
JUSTICE AND HUMAN DECENCY.
DON'T BLAME PEOPLE FOR THINGS
THEY DIDN'T DO.
THE OTHER THING IS, CHRIS CUOMO
IS COMING UNDER FIRE FOR HELPING
HIS BROTHER IN THE MIDDLE OF
THIS CRISIS.
WE CAN'T EVALUATE HOW TRUE THAT
IS.
BUT IF IT IS TRUE, LET'S BE REAL
FOR A SECOND.
IT'S UNDERSTANDABLE.
IT'S HIS BROTHER.
YOUR LOYALTY SHOULD BE TO YOUR
FAMILY ABOVE ALL ELSE.
NOT JOKING AT ALL.
MAYBE ABOVE YOUR JOB.
MAYBE ABOVE JEFF ZUCKER.
IF YOUR BROTHER CALLS AND SAYS I
NEED HELP.
IF YOU DON'T GIVE HIM HELP
BECAUSE YOU'RE PRETENDING TO BE
AN ANCHOR ON A CHANNEL THAT
NOBODY WATCHES, YOU'RE GOING
BACK ON YOUR BROTHER.
TOTALLY TRUE.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO CRITICIZE HIM
FOR THAT.
ONE MORE PIECE OF